TRAGIC EXAMPLE OF WHY THE LAW ON
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IS SO
IMPORTANT.
STILL TONIGHT AS WE SPEAK,
DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING TO SHUT
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT TO SPITE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOINING US IS TAMMY BRUCE,
FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM
BONDI AND FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
MATT GRATES.
I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
I WANT TO GO FIRST TOT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
YOU’VE BEEN THROUGH THESE TYPES
OF EVENTS.
FLORIDA’S A BIG STATE, LIKE
CALIFORNIA.
A BLUE ALERT HAS BEEN ISSUED.
WHAT ARE THE MEN AND WOMEN
THINKING ABOUT AND GOING THROUGH
NOW AS THEY’RE TRYING TO FIND
THIS KILLER?
>> IT’S HORRIBLE.
SADLY, WE’VE DEALT WITH THIS SO
MANY TIMES.
IF NANCY PELOSI WANTS TO PUT $5
BILLION ON A WALL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN, SHE’S SAYING, WHAT
ABOUT THAT POLICE OFFICER’S
CHILD?
THAT’S PRICELESS.
YOU CAN’T PUT A PRICE TAG ON
THAT, JASON.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO BUILD
THIS WALL.
THESE FAMILIES, THESE POLICE
OFFICERS RISK THEIR LIVES FOR US
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND IF HIS LIFE COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED BY THAT WALL, THEN IT
WAS WORTH EVERY PENNY OF IT.
ONE DRUG BUST, JASON, THAT CAME
IN, ONE DRUG BUST IN ONE DAY
COMING THROUGH THE MEXICAN
BORDER, IT WAS COCAINE, METH AND
HEROIN TOTALLING OVER HITS OR
DOSES THAT COULD GO TO CHILDREN,
31 MILLION DOSE.
I GOT IT ALL BROKEN DOWN BY DEA
FOR ME.
THAT’S ALMOST THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALL THOSE KIDS IN OUR COUNTRY,
ALL THOSE DRUGS COULD HAVE GONE
TO KIDS IN OUR COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN.
THAT’S WHY THESE BORDERS ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
THE GANGS, THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
FIRSTHAND I KNOW ABOUT ALL OF
THIS.
>> JASON: TAMMY, THIS IS BROADER
THAN JUST THE WALL.
I KNOW THE DISCUSSION IS ABOUT
THE WALL.
THE WALL IS IMPORTANT.
PUT SOMETHING IN BETWEEN THOSE
WHO WANT TO COME NORTH.
IT IS BIGGER AND BROADER THAN
JUST THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
BRINGING KIDS ACROSS THE BORDER.
DRUGS AND GUNS AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS THAT COME ALONG WITH
THAT.
AND WE DON’T KNOW HOW THIS
PERSON THAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS THE POLICE.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW THIS PERSON
GOT HERE.
COULD HAVE COME UNDER A VISA AND
BE A VISA OVERSTAY.
BUT THERE STILL IS NEED TO BUILD
THE WALL AND CREATE AN
IMPEDIMENT, CORRECT?
>> THERE’S THE LITERALNESS OF
THAT, JASON.
BUT THERE’S ALSO THE PSYCHOLOGY
OF IT.
IT’S A STATEMENT TO INDIVIDUALS
LIKE THIS CRIMINAL, WHO THOUGHT
HE WOULD JUST COME OVER.
THE INDIVIDUALS, BRAZILIAN
MURDERERS WHO ICE HAS CAUGHT WHO
THERE’S THIS MESSAGE THAT THIS
THEY HAD TO SEND BACK TO BRAZIL.
IS THE PLACE TO ESCAPE TO IF
SOMEONE ELSE IS LOOKING FOR YOU.
OR THAT, IN FACT, IF AMERICA
DOESN’T CARE ABOUT ITS BORDER
SECURITY AND DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
CRIME AND WHAT’S HAPPENING
INSIDE THE COUNTRY, WHY SHOULD
YOU?
I JUST HAVE TO SAY, THIS IS
EERILY SIMILAR AND HORRIFIC AS
WELL AS WHAT REMINDED PEOPLE
DURING THE CAMPAIGN WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE KATE STEINLY KILLING ON THE
PIER IN SAN FRANCISCO.
UP UNTIL THAT POINT, THAT WAS
ALL THIS KIND OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE TECHNICALITIES OF
IMMIGRATION AND WHAT WE WERE
GOING TO HAVE AS BORDERS AND THE
IMPEDIMENTS AND ALL OF THAT.
WE’VE MOVED INTO THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION AGAIN, WHERE IT’S
AB THESE ELEMENTS, OR THE
DEMOCRATS GETTING THEIR VOTES OR
IF THEY’RE GOING TO WIN IN 2020.
SUDDENLY WE REALIZE IT’S THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO MATTER HERE.
THAT THE POLITICIANS ARE USING
US AS EFFECTIVELY OR SEEING US
AS COLLATERAL DAMAGE AS THEY
MIGHT TO GET WHAT THEY WANT.
THIS ISN’T A FIGHT ABOUT US,
ABOUT OUR FAMILIES, ABOUT THAT
LITTLE BABY NOW WHO WILL NEVER
KNOW HIS FATHER AND ALL OF THE
PEOPLE IN AMERICA WHO HAVE LOST
A LOVED ONE, EITHER THROUGH
DRUGS OR THROUGH MURDER OR
THROUGH KILLINGS.
THIS IS WHAT WE’VE GOT TO
REMEMBER.
POLITICIANS WANT YOU TO THINK
IT’S ABOUT THEM.
IT IS ABOUT US AND THIS IS WHAT
THE PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED TO.
IT’S OUR LIVES AND OUR FUTURE.
>> JASON: CONGRESSMAN, I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING WITH YOU IN
THE 115TH CONGRESS.
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY’RE FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
I, FOR THE LIFE OF ME, CAN’T
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY THINK IS
BORDER SECURITY, WHEN THEY WANT
TO PROMOTE SANCTUARY CITIES AND
ABOLISH ICE.
THEY CALL THE WALL IMMORAL.
THEY AREN’T SUPPORTING THE WALL.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY THINK
BORDER SECURITY IS.
BUT THERE’S A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.
THEY SUDDENLY WANT TO HAVE A
HEARING.
THERE SHOULD BE AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORT.
THE CHILD THAT WAS IN -- NOW TWO
CHILDREN IN THE CUSTODY OF
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL.
I DO THINK THERE SHOULD BE AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THAT.
WHAT ABOUT THESE KILLINGS?
DO YOU THINK THEY’LL DO SOME
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THOSE?
>> IT IS ALWAYS A TRAGEDY WHEN A
CHILD DIES.
OBVIOUSLY, WE’RE GOING TO LOOK
INTO THAT.
MY GOODNESS, IF YOU DID WHAT THE
LEFT WANTED, YOU’D GET RID OF
THE BORDERS, ABOLISH ICE, HAVE
EVERY CITY AS A SANCTUARY CITY.
YOU’D PROVIDE THEM BETTER THAN
THE VETERANS ARE GETTING IN MY
DISTRICT AND MY OWN COMMUNITY.
LOOK AT THE CHALLENGES THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONDI LAID OUT,
BEFORE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS.
THEY’VE ALREADY GOT TO FIGHT
AGAIN AMERICAN MURDERERS.
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO FIGHT
AGAINST MURDERERS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD THAT ARE DUMPED HERE
BECAUSE OF OUR POROUS BORDER.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THE
WALL, RISING WAGES FOR THE
AMERICAN WORKER, SAFER STREETS
THAT DON’T HAVE THE DRUG.
I THINK WHAT MOTIVATES OUR
PRESIDENT THE MOST IS THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
REMEMBER, JASON, HE’S MET WITH
THE FAMILIES OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES AT THE
HANDS OF CRIMINALLY ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHO WERE VIOLENT.
IT’S THAT COMMITMENT TO THE
FAMILIES THAT LOST LOVED ONES
THAT MOTIVATES THE PRESIDENT TO
BE SO RESOLUTE DURING THIS
PERIOD OF TIME.
I’M CONFIDENT THE PRESIDENT WILL
GET A GOOD DEAL HERE.
WE CANNOT PUT ILLEGAL ALIENS
OVER THE INTEREST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT SOUNDS SO OBVIOUS TO SAY.
YOU LOOK AT WHO EVERYONE’S
FIGHTING FOR.
THE PRESIDENT IS FIGHTING FOR
SAFER STREET, BETTER JOBS AND
HIGHER WAGES.
APPARENTLY THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FIGHTING FOR A POROUS BORDER
THAT BECOMES EASIER FOR CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
A SHAME.
>> JASON: THAT’S WHAT’S AMAZING.
DEMOCRATS ARE MORE INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE NANCY PELOSI GETS
THE GAVEL AND BECOMES THE
SPEAKER.
THEY WANT BORDER SECURITY.
THEY CAN’T DEFINE WHEN THEY SAY
WHEN IT WASN’T DONALD TRUMP THEY
VOTED TO AUTHORIZE THE WALL.
NOW THEY WON’T WANT TO FUND IT.
SO THE DISCUSSION CONTINUES.
I WISH I HAD MORE TIME FOR ALL
THREE OF YOU, BUT WE DON’T.
THERE’S A LOT OF NEWS HAPPENING.